swimming in your quad or something
spiritual and I am gonna get every time
you spend the night
so um how did um how'd you plan how do
you come up with the idea for this uh
this live stream uh well we wanted to
live stuff for a while and a lot of our
audiences international overseas and so
you figured why not do it on YouTube
which is where our audiences and said I
want to see it and how did you assemble
why do you assemble these like you know
making a call Sam Tsui I mean because
they're awesome I've worked through them
all before so they're great people
they're great musicians and peered why
not why not why not work with awesome
people haha great and what have you guys
been you know doing in the run-up to
this to tomorrow's event uh well
figuring out how to do it for one thing
I mean we've got to switch between
cameras live and do the sound mix all in
real time and make sure people can watch
it okay so kind of figuring out the
technical end and just making sure if
people have good experience watching it
I'm noticed throughout the days you know
you're trying to figure out no blogging
and yeah you know it's like everything
kind of everything is important so you
know just trying to fit it all together
you talk about you know you're talking
about your fans you want to bring this
out to your fans like what else are you
doing to make this event special for
your fans well fans can interact with us
in real time which is something new for
us when so we're performing a bunch but
then we also want to talk to the fans
and answer questions so people can
comment live and as we're playing they
can type questions and whatever and
hopefully we'll answer as many as we can
and get to that because you know
directly talking to our fans in real
time on the internet is not something
that we can do very often I don't think
anyone has really done something like
what we're doing on youtube before um
we're live-streaming switching between a
bunch of cameras having people with
large YouTube followings performing live
so you know hopefully it's the first of
many and what also we looking forward to
when once this is over what other
projects do you have well I'm producing
Sam's debut album so that'll be a ton of
fun and hopefully we'll be releasing
that early next year and it's always is
much more videos in the work so you know
just check it out
what do you find so innovative about
this this live life event I'm assuming
this is this your first time doing yeah
yeah I mean it's definitely you know I
haven't seen anything like this before
on YouTube um you know people have done
live streaming concerts you know but not
necessarily on the actual website
YouTube which makes it a lot easier for
fans you know you don't have to log into
some other site and figure out some
username and pass you just can go to you
know the channel like you would see any
other video and it'll be right there so
it's super easy and this live stream
feature has been on YouTube for a little
while now and some people have done have
done little mini streaming concerts but
they've all been on a much smaller scale
and that you know they'll set up like a
webcam style like either talk back or
little mini concert but this is you know
done you know in a much more high scale
sort of sense we have you know rely
vexing the audio we have a bunch of
cameras it's we're making sure it's
going to look and sound really high
quality and that's something that I
don't think has really been done before
in this youtube streaming format give me
a new revenue like you know concerns
about you know what could happen no I
mean I I trust Kurt and the whole sort
of tech team it's I mean I can't imagine
how complicated it must be to be having
all these video feeds and audio feeds
and mixing them live and then sending
them out and having it appear on the
channel live I'm sure there's an
incredible amount of crazy tech stuff
that's involved with that but I I trust
them one hundred percent they know what
they're doing so umm yeah I'm excited
that I can just chill out perform and
know that all the fans are going to get
to see it
you know what makes this uh what makes
this live stream so special for your
fans I mean it's different from
performing to live audience and you're
performing in free but people always and
anywhere you can get a Wi-Fi connection
um I think what makes it so special is
you know I haven't really gotten a
chance to go to everywhere to reform me
I've only been to a few places so it's a
chance for people who haven't gotten the
chance to see me perform live for them
to be able to watch me and how do you
prepare how do you prepare for such for
such an event I mean it's not like yeah
it is different from just different from
you know like being on being on a stage
or I mean this looks from what I'm
saying it looks like it's being filmed
today in the studio so it's like if like
I wish it to be recorded well it's not
like yeah cuz usually whenever you like
a live show you get to like feed off the
audience's energy and stuff but I'm
definitely going to be different but you
know we're just all up there just making
music and having fun and hopefully the
fancy that and enjoy it and how are you
trying to how are you trying to make
interact with your fans and this is um I
think in between like sets are going to
be taking some questions from your fans
and then give them some answers
you bring me too bad please you make me
testify are you feeling feeling all
right into the run up with this event I
mean it's it's I can't wait for it so
it's so exciting you know we never done
something like this before curse never
done something like this before I've
never done something like this before
and I think it's gonna be really
exciting for everybody i really hope
that everybody who's watching enjoys it
and and know is that it's so cool
because it's it's really live and it's
out of there on the internet and they
can interact with us at the same time I
feel like that's something that really
hasn't been done before and I'm really
am honored to be a part of that and how
are you how are you interacting with
your friend you would your fans the hump
and run up to the show oh I mean I love
any any support of my love being you
know we're all people I love interacting
as much as I can and and you know really
they're a part of my family if they're
if they're if they're fans are
supporters of me and I really love the
fact that I can just tell them straight
up it's like I'm telling all my friends
then hey people you just watch this live
concert we're doing and you know it's
free and it's awesome it's fun and and I
hope they enjoy it so I've been just
telling everybody about and doing a
little secret tweets and stuff and I'm
excited and you know you this is pretty
dick this is a different from you know
performing live on stage you're here and
it's sending a student just watching hmm
people are watching it like people
watching in a studio so how how is
preparing for like an event like this
life like a live stream different from
you know performing live on stage you
know I think um I think any any type of
performance you just gotta give your all
and when i get out on stage I really
feed off the energy of that audience and
it's and it's always tough for me
because that's my favorite thing feed
off the energy of the audience in person
but I think it'll be really interesting
to feel like you know we know in the
same way there are all these people that
are watching we might not be in the same
room with them but we still have to feed
off that potential energy and feed off
each others energy in and you know I'm
really excited that we got a live band
and everything that sort as well though
so we can feed off each other and I
think it's really cool the setup is is
very is very intimate and because of
that we can really connect with the
music a lot more so than if it were on a
really big stage which is one of the
benefits
so I'm really I'm really delighted that
it is it turned out in that way and what
else do you find so innovative about
this this life is that I mean what I
find the most innovative not only
because it's you know it's live
broadcast but something that I feel like
you you don't get as much in some you
know TV show environments as such is the
interaction is the immediate interaction
because you know if we're sitting there
with computers and really seeing what
people are saying and talking about it
in the moment that I feel like that's a
connection that is that's so powerful
and so special in that exact moment and
and and that's what I think is one of
the most innovative things about this is
you know the Internet in general just
bringing people if people are walk
watching and Hawaii or Asia or in
Australia anywhere in the world they can
all be interacting at once in one place
and that's that's so cool its own
right which way is wrong
say that it
oh yay
you are you are you